so you want to bring back the woolly
mammoth bring back woolly mammoths maybe
you love elephants maybe you love
science or maybe you just want to make a
lot of money either way we are
remarkably close to being able to do it
and the opportunity here is a lot bigger
than most people think naturally though
there are tons of skeptics bad ideas did
no one see jurassic car and sure no one
wants a group of woolly mammoths
charging around killing people but this
project could have a profoundly positive
impact on the world so let's dig into it
and figure out how it would work what
the benefits are and lastly how much
money it could actually make genetic
engineering is a complex issue and i
don't think we should ignore the ethical
questions yeah but your scientists were
so preoccupied with whether or not they
could they didn't stop to think
so let's take jeff goldblum's advice and
stop to think about whether or not we
should actually resurrect the woolly
mammoth
[Music]
first up is the why these creatures have
been dead for thousands of years do we
really need them and could they even
survive if we did bring them back well
unlike the dinosaurs which died off
millions of years ago mammoths and
humans coexisted for millennia at least
until we killed them all early man ate
the woolly mammoth out of existence 12
000 years ago most of them went extinct
because we ate them so you could argue
that humanity has some sort of moral
obligation to bring them back since we
were the ones responsible for their
ultimate demise
but there's a bigger reason for bringing
them back and it's a lot more selfish
bringing back the woolly mammoth could
actually help prevent climate change and
that benefits us directly see the
permafrost is melting and that's a big
problem for us we need to keep these icy
regions frozen as long as possible if we
want to control carbon emissions and the
reason we want lower temperature in the
tundra is that there are 1400 billion
tons of carbon locked up not too far
from the surface in the icy soil and it
is melting very quickly woolly mammoths
accomplished several really important
tasks up in the tundra they knock down
trees and clear whole forests this is a
bit counter-intuitive because we think
of trees as generally important to
environmental protection but up in the
arctic clearer grasslands usually
reflect more sunlight and stay colder as
mammoths walk around the tundra they
pack down the snow and create sheets of
ice that actually keep the permafrost
colder there are bison up in the tundra
and they do a pretty good job of
clearing smaller shrubs but they can't
knock down whole trees so repopulating
northern russia and canada with woolly
mammoths might actually be able to slow
the permafrost melt and buy us some
extra time to fight climate change it
isn't going to solve everything but it
seems like it's worth a shot but there
are other great reasons to support this
project it's just plain inspiring i
firmly believe that seeing astronauts go
to space is incredibly inspirational any
child that sees a rocket launch
immediately wants to learn more about
the science and technology that made
that possible that's really important
since physics isn't exactly the easiest
subject this woolly mammoth project
could do the same for the biological
sciences seeing this ancient creature
reincarnated would undoubtedly inspire a
new generation of biologists and they
would go on to do all sorts of great
things we shouldn't discount the
application of de-extinction technology
more broadly though the woolly mammoth
is fun to talk about because it's such a
striking creature everyone knows what a
woolly mammoth is and who doesn't want
to see one in real life but the same
genetic technology that will help create
a new mammoth will also help restore
other species on the brink of extinction
and this is actually happening already
the black-footed ferret is one great
example this species was declared
extinct in 1980 but just last year
scientists were able to clone a
black-footed ferret that had died
decades earlier to help bring the
species back and this happens all the
time a particular species becomes so
rare that there isn't enough genetic
diversity in the remaining animals to
continue reproducing but cloning older
animals can help prevent outright
extinction clearly there are risks to
any cutting edge science but we aren't
talking about resurrecting deadly
dinosaurs after all these woolly
mammoths are remarkably close to
elephants and elephants have been
outmatched by modern firearms for
decades but you're probably asking
yourself how would this even work can
you bring back the woolly mammoth
because i would love to see one uh i
love a woolly steak well if you've seen
jurassic park you'll probably remember
that the original dinosaur dna was found
preserved in amber and something
remarkably similar happened with the
woolly mammoth it's basically impossible
for us to find intact dinosaur dna due
to the natural decay that occurs over
millions of years even if blood was
preserved in amber radiation would have
ripped the dna sequences to shreds over
such a long period of time but the
mammoths only died off thousands not
millions of years ago and many mammoths
were frozen in ice as soon as they died
which preserved them remarkably well and
the story of how we found these
incredible specimens is actually pretty
crazy too ivory is one of the most
valuable materials in the world and the
only way to get it is from elephants or
at least it used to be with elephant
populations dwindling governments
started restricting the sale of elephant
ivory but russian ivory hunters figured
out an alternative after embargo
for elephant people started to sell
memos there were no restrictions on
digging up frozen mammoths and selling
the ivory from their tusks so a small
industry started to flourish life
uh
finds a way as these mammoth hunters dug
deeper and deeper they started finding
bodies that were so perfectly frozen
they appeared to actually bleed when
they were cut open this was an
incredibly promising breakthrough since
these preserved specimens might have
enough dna left in them to piece
together a complete sequence this is the
stuff that could possibly clone and
bring back the mammoth from its
extinction so in other words i'm
literally holding a plot line from
jurassic park in my hand now to be clear
we haven't found any living mammoth
cells just dna fragments and that's an
important distinction scientists
essentially need to piece together these
fragments to understand what genes
produce the traits that allowed the
woolly mammoth to thrive in such harsh
environments it would be great if we
could just relocate some african or
asian elephants to the tundra and call
it a day but they wouldn't last long up
there it's just too cold the woolly
mammoth is genetically similar to
today's elephants but has a few key
traits that allow it to survive in low
temperatures thick fur extra layers of
fat and hemoglobin to carry oxygen in
the blood are all critical
differentiators but the dna sequences
that code for those genes are pretty
well understood now right now a team of
geneticists at harvard run by a
narcoleptic dyslexic genius named dr
george church are on the verge of
bringing back the woolly mammoth george
church is at the center of this project
and just co-founded a company named
colossal to commercialize the effort to
clone a willy mammoth and he's not just
some crazy scientist well maybe he's a
bit crazy but he is definitely well
respected within the scientific
community in 1984 church published the
first direct genome sequencing method
and played a critical role in the human
genome project he's been working on this
mammoth project for the last six years
and he clearly really believes in it
this is real not science fiction and is
potentially applicable to endangered and
extinct species there are two major
trends that are simultaneously
accelerating to make something like this
a real possibility first the cost of dna
sequencing is falling incredibly fast
twenty years ago sequencing a single
genome cost a hundred million dollars
now it costs less than a thousand
dollars biology is becoming drastically
more accessible and that's opening up
tons of new opportunities the second
major trend is in gene editing
technology crispr is the latest
development in this area and the
creators just won the nobel prize for
their work on it last year you can think
of these two developments like reading
and writing in order to clone a mammoth
we need to be able to read old mammoth
dna and then write that dna to a new
embryo the cost of reading dna has
fallen precipitously and now the cost of
writing dna is also falling but even
with these advances directly cloning a
mammoth is still a bit out of reach
luckily scientists have found a
workaround instead of trying to create a
perfect replica they are just going to
focus on adding those key genes i
mentioned earlier into an asian elephant
essentially creating a hybrid this
wouldn't be an exact replica because the
short dna fragments that i told you
about will prevent us from building the
exact structure but it would make
something that looked and felt very much
like a woolly mammoth did and this is a
really key strategy the team working on
this project isn't getting hung up on
satisfying some vague technical notion
of what constitutes a mammoth they just
want to make something that will get the
job done in the tundra but now to the
really vital part the economic
opportunity church spun out his research
into a full company and they just raised
15 million dollars so they have to start
thinking about turning a profit now the
first and most obvious way for his
company colossal to make money is just
to sell cloned mammoths this is pretty
straightforward countries that have
melting permafrost could buy mammoths
from colossal directly and then turn
them loose in areas that are the most
affected by warming climates but there
could be plenty of other buyers zoos
already spent a fortune on rare animals
and a cloned woolly mammoth would
clearly be the rarest of all pandas
routinely sell for over one million
dollars and they're only endangered
there's also a long history of cloned
animals selling for incredibly high
prices sir lancelot encore is a cloned
dog estimated to be worth millions of
dollars and a company named cynogene
clones cats and dogs regularly for
around fifty thousand dollars a piece
missy the cow sold for 1.2 million
dollars in 2009 and she wasn't even
cloned so there's clearly a market for
rare animals with very specific dna
sequences i could definitely see the
market for cloned mammoths being
extremely lucrative even if it was only
for a few years before the novelty wore
off after all one of the investors in
colossal's funding round was the tick
tock star josh richards he hasn't
disclosed how much money he put in but i
wouldn't be surprised if he could make
it all back just by being the first
influencer to do a dance on top of a
woolly mammoth but there are still other
ways that this company could make money
and they might not even need to sell any
mammoths to do it church teamed up with
a serial entrepreneur named ben lam to
found colossal and ben has an
interesting history in startups his last
company was an artificial intelligence
business named hypergiant if you've
never heard of them that's to be
expected even though they have a really
slick website they don't make
consumer-facing products instead the
company focuses on partnerships with big
companies who operate in the aerospace
and defense industry so this project
could be an attempt to do something
similar attract a bunch of really
incredible talent to an ambitious
project and then make money licensing
out intellectual property and
contracting with other biotech companies
either way church clearly takes the
implications of his work very seriously
we are taking more and more control over
our biological
destiny the ability to both read and
write dna is a truly incredible
breakthrough and one that we shouldn't
take lightly we need to be careful about
the second order effects of these
projects but that shouldn't slow us down
big problems require big ambitious
solutions and i for one hope this
project succeeds thanks for watching
[Music]